[MUSIC PLAYING]
ABDUR-RAHMAN EL-SAYED: We
established the company back
in 2012.
Back then, if you wanted to
read Arabic news on mobile,
it was very, very hectic.
We decided to solve this problem
by building a personalized
Arabic news reader that is
able to aggregate all the news
and deliver it to the
right person based
on their preference and
based on their location.
ABDULLAH EL-SAYED:
Android has the majority
of the smartphone market
share in the Middle East.
So we knew that
publishing Nabd on Android
was key to our success.
Since we launched
Nabd on Google Play,
we have seen the app growing
massively in a very short time.
Currently, 60% of our users
are on the Android platform.
The number of daily
installs we get on Android
is two times higher
than other platforms.
User engagement is
extremely high on Nabd.
Users can share
stories, favorite them,
or comment on them within
the Nabd community.
Every quarter, there is
over 7 million stories
that are being shared on social
networks by Android users.
And we found that
the average number
of shared stories per user
is 20% higher on Android
than other platforms.
One of the reasons why
engagement on Android is higher
is the fact that we
implemented material design.
When material design
was announced,
we were impressed with
the new visual style
and the functionalities.
It took us three months to
redesign the app completely
and make the transition
to material design.
One of the major changes
we've done in the new version
was adding a Material
Design tab layout.
We shifted one of the
sections from the side menu
to the tab layout, and we found
that the users who discovered
the section increased by 400%.
Once we redesigned the app, we
used store-listing experiments
to find the optimal
screenshots and the best
order of screenshots
that lead to the highest
number of installs.
We also found that having a
video in your store listing
increases conversions by 8%.
Material Design had
a significant impact
on user behavior.
For us, the most
exciting part was
to see that the number
of five-star ratings
actually tripled
after the new version.
We constantly use
Google Analytics
to understand the
behavior of users
and how they interact
with the app.
And based on our analysis, we
optimized the design of the app
in order to get
the best results.
ABDUR-RAHMAN EL-SAYED:
Three years ago, there
was no such thing as Nabd.
Today we're over 25
people across four offices
in Kuwait, Saudi Arabia, Dubai,
Egypt, and very soon in Turkey.
And that feels amazing.
It's a joy and a passion
that I can't really explain.